[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Josh is
in Albany New York Josh welcome to the
Ramsey show how you doing hey Fells
thanks a ton for taking the time to chat
with me today
appr hey uh so I find myself kind of at
a bit of a positive Financial Crossroads
in my life I just started a new job um
in Long Island that pays 125k a year
which is more than double my previous
Sal it's great um but I currently live
in Albany New York so wow I have been
commuting down um and it's about you
know anywhere from six to eight hours a
day of driving depending on traffic oh
hold on a second how long have you been
commuting six to eight hours a day it's
only been two weeks and it is on a
hybrid schedule so I'm only in the
office two days at the moment so it's
not okay exceptionally brutal um and it
it will probably be three days uh on
site you know moving forward um and my
initial intention was to move down to
the city but the more I do the math the
more I think about it the more I'm
debating just doing the commute and
functionally doubling my already doubled
salary you know oh are you married kids
what's your status no single is a day is
long I don't even have a house plant to
worry about I think it's I think it's
bananas that you're even considering
doing this but the fact that you're
single is the only scenario yeah how old
are you by which I could do that uh 32
32 okay well I'll tell you it's not a
sustainable solution even two or three
days a week your mental health is going
to suffer you'll be calling the Dr John
deloney show uh shortly here because of
this so we've got to find a solution and
if that means finding a different job
finding a job that's closer that can pay
you that or moving to Long Island and
figuring it out maybe you get a roommate
for a while to uh be able to afford the
cost of living idea why don't we why
don't we get rid of the extreme Josh and
why don't we think 30 miles 40 miles
outside of Long Island let's let's let's
get outside a little bit where maybe the
cost of living is not as much as being
you know right there where you work
split the difference uh good ways here
uh I just think you're going to
eventually get miserable you're going to
be miserable with all that and by the
way that's just not good for you and
your health um it's just not good for
you putting a lot of miles on your car
there's just a lot of diminishing
returns to this I'd really like to talk
you out of it okay so let's George is
the best at this all right so I'm I'm
gonna I'm going to tap George here on
the shoulder tag team here let's talk
him through roommate let's walk through
his raise Plus cost of living let's walk
through this here's what happens Josh
people tend to go I've got a and b a is
I stay in Alban at commute eight hours
or b i mve to Long Island and broke and
I go what about CDE e f you go down
through the alphabet here and so let's
talk through those scenarios could you
move closer to Long Island but not
directly in the city and have a half
hour commute 45 minute
commute yeah I mean I think if I'm going
anywhere even close to the city my
minimum commute is already going to be
like an hour you know even unless I can
find something explicitly like in the
township that I would be in but the cost
of living there is actually much higher
because it's kind of a rich area um so
I've been looking at like maybe pipy
something to cut it in half you know
maybe an hour and a half commute each
day much don't mind the drive how much
more does it cost you to live in
pyy uh by the way I love saying that
word I knew it I was just thinking Ken L
saying just came out of my mouth and it
felt so good uh someone say it again
pipsy is there it is uh how much more is
it to live there than where you're
living now in
Albany well my current situation in
Albany my rent is 575 bucks a month
which I'm never going to live this cheap
again in my life yeah are you in a
box no it's actually a great
apartment my room is like 400 square
feet it's gigantic um it's 400 sare feet
is never gigantic but but how much
difference apartment just my bedroom oh
your bedroom okay what's uh what's the
difference in
cost um probably I'm looking at a
minimum of at least $1,500 increase in
rent probably $2,000 in rent for a one
sounds about appropriate yeah probably
15 to 2,000 somewhere in what about a
two-bedroom uh probably only a little
bit more maybe 2200 okay so that's where
I'm going with this you get one roommate
a similar you know guy like you in his
20s early 30s single and just looking to
have a place to crash that's all you're
looking for a guy who's clean who can
pay on time now your rent is 1,00 bucks
right but you also just gained seven
hours of your life back every single day
yeah and not to mention you just doubled
your salary
correct yeah more so more than that okay
so doubling your rent payment is not the
end of the world yeah it's not like
you're going backwards I think think in
your mind you're so stuck on this
unbelievable rent that you have 500
bucks a month which is unbelievable it's
like you're in the Stone Age uh somehow
you've managed that that's phenomenal
good for you but you're looking at that
in the increase over that and you're not
looking at how much better your life is
this great job that you love uh you're
over double your salary I I think you
need to be focusing on that and this is
about stretching and growing and you can
you can handle a $1,500 a month one
bedroom that's not outrageous given the
money he's making yeah do you have any
debt uh just my car which is about
$32,000 but that's it how much do you
owe on
that uh on the car is it
32 yeah 32 oh what's it
worth um probably about that it's a 2022
subar R back I just bought it earlier
this year dud you are just appreciating
the snot out of that thing with all that
driving you're going to put a 100,000
miles on that thing in a year the way
you're going that's the number one
reason to move is that right
there yeah that you're going to be
underwater on that car if you aren
already is going to be screaming at you
swearing at you puffing I'd get you a
Prius if you're going to be driving
seven hours a day there you go but yeah
I think you know what to do Josh the
hard part is letting go of this amazing
rent and dealing with the idea of having
a roommate and moving again but man it
it is worth it you doubled your income
and there's got to be some sacrifices
that come along with that if you're
going to keep this job long term yep
yeah no I appreciate it thank you yeah
you got this man you're not you're not
doing anything crazy I mean he's really
nervous about that rent I can't picture
taking a road trip every single day just
to go to work and back I when is he
leaving the house 2 a.m. he's probably
not sleeping I didn't want to ask that
CU I honestly it I was afraid I was
going to break out in a rash just for
him just the the the the the anxiety of
thinking about uh six to did he say six
to seven hours 6 to8 hours total 6 8
hours we're talking that's probably
three or four each way I imagine and
then he goes well it was only a couple
days a week I don't care if it's once a
month that would drive me bananas no
thank you I don't like to be in a car
very long you need your beauty sleep you
don't get this with 3 hours 4 hours of
sleep look you know I got it it takes a
few minutes to do this hair too this
doesn't happen in a couple minutes
there's a process here George we both
have our process well I don't think your
personal sanity your physical health
your mental health is worth commuting to
that job even if it's a dream job yeah
live in a nightmare do not forget that
that hampers your ability to do your job
well and potentially get promoted so
this is a holistic life decision here I
hope I hope he goes closer